all right my guest this week is the host
of CNN tonight self-proclaimed king of
Twitter and one of the few guys in cable
news not afraid to tell you what he
really thinks Don Lemon what's going on
it's called Cena tonight with Don Lemon
okay a with Don Lemon with Don limit how
long did you have to fight to get that
in there not that I'm picky listen it's
everything is important it all matters
Dave Rubin how are you I'm doing good it
actually it does all matter and it's
funny that you say that because that I
think that's a good place to start
because you have been on this like
upward thing forever we've known each
other for probably like four or five
years now and you did my old Sirius XM
show a long time ago and and you were
you were subbing in for a lot of people
you were jumping around show to show but
you have your own gig now pretty good
right it is pretty good I mean it's
weird because people say you've been on
this upward trajectory Volvo it doesn't
feel that way when you're living it
right I'm still the same guy um
it still feels the same and I'm still
you know the struggle is real but but
it's great to be in prime time on a
major network I mean you know you kind
of it doesn't get any better than this a
show with my name on it
there I had no complaints and very I
live every moment in gratitude right now
yeah so there's there's a lot of stuff I
wanted to have the first show of the
year with you because you're in the
thick of it right like every time I turn
on the news and something's going down
somewhere they send you there or you're
at the studio or you're interviewing
somebody so I thought you'd be the
perfect person to sort of kick the year
off with but let's get a little bit
first what's like the day-to-day
operations so you have your show at
night what's going on in the in the
world of Don Lemon all day long well it
depends on it depends on the day but I
mean pretty much every night I'm on the
air at 10:00 p.m. and every night
between 7:00 and 8:00 I have a rundown
meeting and every single morning at
10:30 I have an editorial meeting and
then someday if I'm up I try to do the
network editorial call at 9:00 so it can
be a very long day and then I do radio
on some mornings at 7:00 this is all
Eastern Time yeah about 7:00 7:15
Eastern Time so it depends if it's a day
I do radio I'm up at 6:45 seven o'clock
and I'm giving an editorial on the Tom
Joyner Morning Show and then I try to
read in from then and reach the papers
are at my door and then I try to stay
awake and if I do I do
nine o'clock editorial call and if I
don't I wake up at 10:30 for my show's
editorial call and then I'll try to go
back to sleep but then sometimes other
shows will call and ask me to do live
shots to do something I cover the night
before I'm going to cover the that night
or I'll do an interview with Donald
Trump or coming to a taping like I did
today with Rand Paul it just really
depends so there's no set schedule so
sometimes I get to sleep other times I
don't and that's it and so you said
usually I'm here I try to be unless I
don't have any sleep up the latest I'll
get in is probably like 6:00 or 6:30
yeah but usually I try to get in about
4:00 or 4:30 and you're taking you're
taking naps in that is your office right
there I saw you lets you blanket so you
do take that out just before you just
before we hooked up on skype yeah we
connected on skype be careful be careful
on the couch and by you know crystal
right I do yeah crystal came in and said
hey what are you doing don't go to sleep
you got a Skype with Dave Rubin in 15
minutes I'm like I know I know Dave
he'll be fine I'll be fine you know it's
funny even the way that you started
saying hook up there and then you
immediately have to head your bets
because you're one of these people and I
want to talk about this a little later
on that everything that you say becomes
like this sort of hot button thing but
before we before we delve into all that
stuff
how much news do you actually have to
consume every day because I know I do an
interview show once a week but I'm in
the news constantly I'm always paying
attention to this stuff and on Twitter
and doing this whole thing and there's a
certain amount of bandwidth I think that
you only have in your brain to absorb
all this stuff but you have to know sort
of all the stuff that's going on all the
time that's a very good point um and
sometimes I can I could I consume so
much that I forget right like oh yeah I
knew that like someone will say
something and I'll go yeah that's right
I knew like like um today I was sent out
a note on wayne lapierre 'he's flip-flop
on um background checks yeah then
someone else reminded me that we did it
before I'm like oh yeah that's right we
did do that before and
then and I looked at why he did it so
there's a you know he has a perfectly
legitimate explanation in his head why
he did it but so does you just forget so
um what I try to do quite honestly is
not to UM I try to be informed without
being inundated mm-hmm because you don't
have to know every single thing that's
going on in the world and I don't my
show doesn't cover every single thing
that's going on in the world I don't do
it a traditional rundown news show like
stack like now this now this now this
it's pretty much a theme and it is the
biggest story of the day or the hottest
topic or the talker of the day and
usually we try not to do too many
subjects or we try to make them all
relate and we don't do a lot of stars
like traditionally you know when Piers
was here and when Larry was here the
hours that I'm in now were like very
star heavy and focus and they didn't do
very well and so we do water cooler talk
provocative conversation have
conversations that people will have at
home but not necessarily on television
and it's paid off and thank goodness our
ratings are great we're doing great and
you know we're still going yeah how much
of that comes directly from you because
I remember when when you did my show way
back when whatever that was four or five
years ago I think that same week that we
met you had subbed in for Joy Behar over
on HLN and I remember we were having a
drink and you were saying how much you
liked that because it gave you a chance
to sort of be yourself and get out of
the kind of traditional newsman thing so
all these decisions in terms of the
format and all that is that all coming
directly from you well I did shared a
lot of it comes from me and a lot of it
comes from the the team our staff the
producers and our executive producer
Jonathan wall who's really great with
ideas and then I'll have ideas as well
it depends on the day sometimes like now
you know it's a no-brainer the president
is having this big Town Hall with
Anderson in this game he may he did this
thing at the White House we're going to
talk about guns right we're going to
talk about executive orders and and so
it's that's pretty easy we're going to
talk about what's happening in Oregon so
sometimes it's just pretty
self-explanatory it's our show it's
great to find
we have a show I know and that I don't
have to call a newscast because it's not
a newscast although when it needs to be
we can quickly become a newscaster on
that we can give you I can give you the
30 second or 15 second elevator pitch
between one floor biggest story of the
day or biggest talkers otherwise it does
not fit I don't care if you're a movie
star I don't care who you are if it's
not if it has nothing to do with the
news if it's not relevant it's not
coming on the show yeah that simple all
right so before we get into all the meat
and we're going to talk politics and
guns and all that kind of stuff how did
you get into this thing did you always
want to be on TV did you always want to
be a news guy what brought little Don
Lemon to be over at Time Warner Center
right now I was always curious as a kid
and um when I we would go out and about
my parents I write about this in my book
which is called transparent by the way
yeah that I would just talk to everybody
and you know my mom would like come and
grab me and the restaurant my dad would
always say don't teach him to be afraid
of people and my mom said after that
conversation she'd just let me go so I
would just ask people like what are you
here you on vacation and you're doing
I've just always been curious I don't
necessarily think that it I wanted to be
on television although I liked it I
always wanted to be a journalist and you
know people remind me when I go home for
holidays and just visit my family that
you remember you in college used to
bring the camera to school remember we
tape this fake show when you were kid
you remember used to carry this camera
around and then or remember we had you
anchor our high school and so I forgot a
lot of those things and so it's always
been there yeah so let's talk about the
gay thing for just a sec because I don't
think we I don't about you let's talk
about your gay thing for a second we can
talk about mine too if you want um
there's so much I can go cuz it wit let
me see that hand makes your left hand oh
yeah I got one of these Wow I got one of
these yeah but that's okay go ahead
youyou can get one too I don't didn't
you just say I think if I'm not mistaken
just on air a couple days ago you said
to somebody why would you get married
didn't you say that to Brooke or
somebody Oh somebody in the crowd why
would you get married I just think that
no I I don't want to create another
controversy yeah I don't see the need to
run off and get married right oh right
away or ever and I don't
fun the marrying kind yeah that listen
my whole thing and I'm pretty sure
you'll agree with me on this is that we
should just have the right the same
right that everybody else has so lutely
yeah if you want to do it do it if you
don't want to do it don't do it like
that's it but that's why I don't even
want to talk about the gay thing much so
we could literally do just a minute on
this but I know I'm just messing with
you because we know each other no no I
know but like I to me like and we've
talked about this privately but like
it's exhausting talking about the gay
thing gay people shouldn't have to think
about it any more than straight people
should have to think about their
sexuality or any of that but anyway you
basically came out when your book came
out so it's about four years ago is that
right okay let's repeal Emily 20 I was
twenty eleven it was funny because I was
talking to a friend in Chicago which was
before I came to work at CNN and he said
because I know people were saying Don
Lemon came out and he's like what do you
mean Don Lemon came out Don Lemon has
always been out yeah so I you know since
I've been out since my 20s but it wasn't
something that I talked about on the air
or shared publicly but my bosses knew I
would bring my boyfriend's to the
Christmas party I mean it wasn't a big
deal but the public didn't know I would
host events for like gay events in
Chicago and now he shows basically out
so when people say you know it took you
45 years to come out I'm like well not
really I I think I had to do it because
there was so much confusion and when
you're in the public eye I think it's
important that you say at least when I
came out that you sort of you had to
make a declaration because it's
important for young people who are at
home people who may be struggling people
who may have doubt and I want people to
know like hey you can be a gay person
and you can host a show on CNN and it is
okay yes so that's the part that I
wanted to talk about because this is
exactly what we talked about four years
ago that there was so much going on with
gay rights there was so much happening
at the moment and in a way as a public
person it's sort of you had like this
extra pressure of if I'm going to talk
about this on air I have to be authentic
about it right like how much of that did
you actually really feel well I no one
forced me I started writing a book about
you know sort of my exploits as a
journalist and writing about my
childhood and you know how I grew up and
whatever and I just thought it would be
disingenuous to write a book like that
and not included so it's like you know
telling everything about your life
except for that you know one important
thing that what that one thing that is
really important it's not all of who I
am um but it is an important part of my
life and I think it's important again
for other people to be able to see
someone like me or like a Dave Rubin who
people who are successful and who just
happened to be gay so yeah there was a
lot of pressure on it
on me and there was a lot of pressure to
as a person of color to come out yeah
isn't it cool how it's so irrelevant I
mean that's even why I'm preface in this
by saying let's just remember to second
yeah listen let me tell you it's
irrelevant to you and it's relevant to
many people who live in big cities like
you're in LA now I'm in New York and we
met with you and in New York um so it
for us it's easy because there I am
there is no space place where I am in
the closet my entire team knows the
audience knows my family knows people at
the barbershop know like I don't really
care what you know Bob at the barbershop
thinks about me or the gay people
yes it's I'm I am completely out and
that is - a lot of people that's not
reality and it's strange to certain
people especially certain demographics
and certain ethnicities people aren't
quite that out yet it I think it's
easier for you as a white man to be out
yeah all right well okay so we'll delve
into some of the racial stuff so my last
thing on the gay thing is do you think
there is something about gay people in
general that there are so many out gay
people in news right now I mean you take
you and you take Cheevers and Anderson
and Rachel Maddow and Thomas Robertson
and you know there's a half out guy on
Fox even he may be out already I'm not
sure I'm not even gonna name him we talk
you don't even have to smile or look at
the camera or whatever but my point is
that for some reason you know Riley yeah
he's definitely gay that guy yeah no but
you stole my point that there's a lot of
out people that people get there there's
something comforting in a weird way or
something about gay people it would be
anything there yes there's something
comforting about gay people we're loving
people we're allowing Mambo but here's
the thing I don't think Dave that those
numbers are any different than any other
profession I think that there have been
some people who are brave enough to step
up in this profession because I feel
that if you're a journalist you take an
oath um much like you do if you
juris doctorate when you become an
attorney if you have it when you you
know you take the medical oath when you
become a doctor I think that journalists
really feel that you know you have an
obligation to inform people you have an
obligation to tell the truth you have an
obligation to be as unbiased and
objective as any human being can be so I
think that when you're in this business
in order to get the truth from people in
order to be truthful you have to live
who you are and if you can't put
different rules on other people that you
put on yourself and so I think that
maybe people are just more visible
because it's a visible medium obviously
and I just think that you know we sort
of take that oath but I don't I think
there are plenty of gay doctors there
are plenty of gay lawyers or plenty of
gay politicians as we have seen there
for gay people in the clergy and on on
and on I don't think it's any different
I just think that we happen to be more
visible for the record I have a friend
who's a gay janitor so we are out we're
in every occupation that there is I know
gay athletes I know gay everything yeah
so there you go